- sorry - I have no idea what I'm doing
that okay so where did we leave off
so guess good news struck she broke up
with her boyfriend and I saw it coming
so actually a little bit prior to the
break-up I actually heard that they were
having a lot of problems so you know
like most breakups it actually ended up
in a lot of heartache for both of them
but as we all know in the science of
relationships the person that gets
dumped always takes it a lot harder if
she saw that dude after the break-up I'm
not gonna live that fool look like hot
garbage actually funny enough a little
bit after they broke up he actually
approached me and apologized to me for
the way he behaved and of course I'm not
one to hold grudges so when he
apologized I accepted it we shook hands
oh we moved on from it but to be honest
with you when he apologized what I
really wanted to say was yo face
now you would think that I would be
smart about the situation right she
single I got the inside scoop so now
it's your boys time to swoop and also
remember a homeboy code didn't count
anymore because that dumbass and I
weren't friends so I was in the green
but of course guess what happened that's
right she got another boyfriend mother
[ __ ] you know one thing I noticed about
her she never really had like that
resting period in between a breakup she
got right back on it like a boom range I
swear it happened just like this are you
single
I'm single David be my boyfriend [ __ ]
there was like two seconds what happened
you know what the funny thing about this
was I wasn't even shocked that she got
with somebody else that fast it was who
she got with that shot the dude that she
got with - my recollection was gay you
and people that is not a joke I
genuinely thought he was gay well
surprise surprise apparently not do you
have any idea how much of a shot to my
self-esteem that was just imagine my
reaction the [ __ ] everybody like her do
don't even like girls beat me to it [ __ ]
by the way he was just metrosexual but
back in the day that turn didn't really
exist so you know if you were skinny
jeans you just you know people assumed
you liked penis i but you know at this
point three years of high school ready
passed so I was already at the point of
slowly starting to give up I mean let's
be real if she saw me the same way that
I saw her you know after three years she
probably would have said something by
now so for the next year that she was
with this guy
I tried never thinking about it but it
work you know sorry as it was everything
reminded me of her and I mean everything
look it's cloudy outside is that's our
favorite weather listen no matter how
hard I tried I couldn't stop thinking
about her and in those small moment that
I actually did I felt lost I think being
that close to someone but somehow
managing to be non-existent to them is
probably one of the worst feelings I've
ever felt I just wanted her to see me
the same way that I saw her and you know
maybe the reason why I never told it was
because I felt that I didn't deserve her
so now let's time-lapse - about a year
later was she and that boyfriend broke
up and now it's our last year of high
school if there was one thing that I
wanted out of my high school experience
was to take her to senior ball so I
mustered up the courage of my tiny
little ball sack to ask her to senior
ball but I did in the sorriest way
possible because I was so scared I typed
it in my phone to give it to my best
friend so he can give it to her so she
can read it and they give me her answer
by the end of school oh [ __ ]
I'm telling you right now that is the
sorriest thing I've ever done in my life
so after school was over I awaited the
verdict I'm gonna tell you something
right now if somebody recorded me and
how I looked before she got there I was
pacing around like a crack head with my
palms sweating a [ __ ] so when she
finally came around the corner and we
had a chance to talk she told me the
most heartbreaking news apparently
somebody already asked and she decided
that she was just gonna go by herself
she didn't want to go with anybody if I
could tell you how I felt that very
moment she said that it honestly felt
like a t-rex donkey kicked me right at
the tip of my penis that's just weird
you but remember what I told you guys
that with every dark cloud there was a
silver lining oh that was a big one
right after she told me that she wanted
to go by herself she also said that she
felt bad for the other guy because she
lied to him cuz she said she was gonna
go with me that's right that's right
people she said yes and let me tell you
something I try to play it off real cool
but the moment she walked away I was
like this
I was going to go to my senior ball with
a girl who I thought about almost every
day of my high school career and this is
where the story gets interesting Oh what
is going on YouTube
now a lot of you haven't asked me why I
don't perform out in LA when's my next
show well I'm here to tell y'all for
those of you who don't know there is a
major major event happening in about a
couple of weeks called collaboration so
you guys want to come out and see me
host the show with alongside Mike song
Korean effects and of course the very
funny and famous comedian pk then go
ahead and check out the info and the
description in the info box below and
you guys can check out how you can get
tickets and come see me perform second
announcement check out the shirt BAM so
I know a lawyer guys have been wondering
why I don't have merged why I haven't
sold my t-shirts in a while and the main
reason why is because I didn't want to
sell a shirt that you guys wouldn't buy
and on top of that I don't want to sell
a shirt that you wouldn't Rock on the
regular and I want you to wear the
clothes despite the fact that even if
you didn't know who I was
you will rock it because you know it
looks fresh so with that in mind
Paul Kim and I decided to go ahead and
start our own clothing line called
go-for-broke if you guys want to know
what go-for-broke means to us it stands
for putting it all on the line no matter
what the cost you know a lot of the
times we are so scared and apprehensive
to go for things that we want and that
we deserve that you just have to go
all-in you have to go for broke you know
before I came to LA I had to give up a
lot in order to move to a city where I
didn't know anybody and I wasn't even
sure what my future outcome was going to
be I left my family my friends my sense
of security I even sold half the things
I own that were worth anything to buy
equipment so I can make these films I
mean it was a pretty scary move and so
because I chose to put it all on the
line and go for broke I am sitting here
before you guys making this video doing
what I love because of all your guys's
love and support so if you guys are
wondering where and when can you get it
that is all going to be released through
my twitter my facebook fan page and more
importantly my instagram so make sure
you guys check those out and I will give
you guys a hard release date on those
social media outlets oh and when you
guys receive and Kopke t do me a favor
make sure you take a picture of it on
instagram and tag me on that [ __ ] why so
I can go ahead and
certainly thank you guys you know
straight up from the bottom of my heart
you know a lot of people might say this
is [ __ ] but I would not be here
without you guys you know everything I
have from the equipment I made to the
skits that I do is because a lot of you
guys support me out there without you
guys as a port man I wouldn't be doing
this so what I'm basically saying is you
know I don't want to tear up with no
food thank you to all you crazy
[ __ ] out there that supported
me from day one and uh y'all you know
what it is
let's get nobody wants that dirty ass
little finger you're the digital er your
Cheerios what you get